(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Minnine] OG Ma has been
collecting and reselling
rare, limited edition street
style clothing and accessories
for over a decade in New York City,
turning what was once a small store
into a six-figure business.
(speaking in foreign language)
- My name is Minnie Driver.
I am an actress, a singer,
and I am an immigrant.
I believe nothing is more
American than its immigrants,
so I'm teaming up with Great Big Story
to celebrate those that have
come here and left their mark.
(dramatic music)
(drums beating)
OG Ma, whose real name is Lam
Shi, moved to New York City
and fell in love with
American street style.
(speaking in foreign language)
Every item Supreme puts
out is limited edition.
A simple box logo tee
from the Supreme store
could run you about $30,
but once it hits the resale market,
that number could be in the hundreds.
OG Ma was one of the first to
see this as an opportunity,
and Unique Hype was born.
But the way she gets
high-end access from Supreme
is a secret she won't reveal.
(speaking in foreign language)
(orchestral music)
Once the word about OG Ma's store spread,
that business became a huge success,
and in 2016 it opened up a Hype
2.0 for a special clientele.
(speaking in foreign language)
And there's some items
that are so valuable
she wouldnt sell them for any price.
(speaking in foreign language)
- It is not for sale, not for sale.
I don't want the money.
(orchestral music)
- [Minnie] OG Ma is an
encyclopedia for street wear,
as she's even attracted
celebrity attention.
- Everyday, a lot of people
ask me for the picture.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Minnie] OG Ma is very
proud to have left her mark
on the retail world,
and has even opened up
a second Unique Hype shop in Hong Kong.
(speaking in foreign language)
(upbeat music)
(bell echoing)